I felt like I can do whatever I wanted
to do on a computer name's Ross McRae
I'm the co-founder and CEO of video amp
I'm 24 years old I went to elementary
school like normally and then I was
home-schooled in middle school and
that's where I really fell in love with
computers and engineering there's a time
where I didn't leave my house for six
months i sat in the same place for six
months and just you know and just
actually grood it to 200-pound like 11
year old I was really chubby and then I
just pretty much just focused on
learning and I kind of stuff and then I
went to high school normally and then I
dropped out of UCLA I've always like
done things differently I'm always kind
of try to find you know the fastest way
to do something most efficiently about
two years ago I was reading a lot of the
trades and you can see that like
traditional networks and and content
owners rated by Nielsen you see the
ratings are going down and down because
people are eyeballs are shifting right
but we really know that know people
aren't stopping and watching video I
mean they're just watching it in
different way so they're beyond the man
or time-shifted or or whether it's you
know recorded on your DVR so we figured
if we were able to bridge the gap and
connect all these devices and allow our
clients to look everything holistically
then it's a win-win for not only the
advertisers but also the media owners
because the media owners can say I have
more audiences so it helps them by
saying we were able to package that
audiences in a more effective way and it
also helps the advertisers because
you're saying now I can target people
were historically was very challenging
to hit on television
my bed is in five years cable is gonna
be everywhere just like TV everywhere
and I think that cable has to escape
their traditional means of just being on
TV and they're going to tape their
content and ship it to the you know
unplugging or going to ot T's like Apple
devices at Roku's and making sure that
they're no longer bounded by just the
living room
you